I want I want to go into one of the
aspects this first aspect that like it
talks about courting it's a great clip
from just pearly actually it talks about
courting and what has happened to
gentlemen and what women are really
looking for in society because I think
this relates to what you were saying
about how women demonize men men
demonize women and what I'm really
trying to figure out in all of this is
what's the truth what's real here like
what is what let's distinguish between a
reaction which is like a defense
knee-jerk reaction to someone what
someone's saying an emotional reaction
oftentimes and what do people actually
feel and what do they actually want so I
want to dig into this Tyler if you can
play that clip please
to give you little devil's advocate here
okay I don't think your generation
really understands this okay for men
like women like guys that sleep around
and and treat like women modern women
don't like men that treat them like
queens and the problem is like if if
guys
aren't sleeping around they start to
like think too highly of each girl and
treat them too well and modern women
don't like that it's not like in your
generation where like a girl's courted
and like they respect it and they're
excited like you can just Court the nice
girl and she she wants you like for them
it's like basically if they give a girl
everything She Wants then she doesn't
like them and girls don't like guys that
don't sleep around like they only want
guys that sleep around I'm just so what
I'm left watching that you know I've
watched it several times and sometimes
I'm like oh I agree and then I'm like
but wait is that 100 right so what world
what I'm trying to figure out about
modern women you know I was in the the
dating World a while ago it's been
several years I'm married it's going to
be five years now I dated my husband for
three years before that so it's been a
while but what I'm trying to figure out
is do modern women do they do they do
they not want like a good guy yeah or do
they just not want a doormat yeah
because there's a different difference
between courting someone and being that
doormat who's like babe what do you need
what can I do you're always available
for them you're always picking up the
phone you're 100 on them you're looking
like you don't have your own life that's
very different from a gentleman who has
his own life has a [ __ ] together is
doing his own thing but also wants to be
that gentleman open those doors invite
you to dinner all of that so I'm trying
to figure out is she right or is she
wrong listen she's right and she's wrong
um and it's and you have to break down
the Nuance of the conversation and I'm
gonna keep on going things to politics
because I think politics is fun I like
what you do I'm gonna make some examples
when you use the term modern women what
are you even that's a loaded word that's
like using the term you're on the right
there's many different kinds of people
on the right you have far right you have
moderate life you have rhinos you have
conservative you have mag you have a lot
of people who are part of that group so
when people use the word Modern Woman
it's like what does that word even mean
what do you what are you entailing is
that Generation Z that Generation Y is
that generation like what what are you
talking about to me that means someone
who's right now in this moment dating
okay so is a 65 year old grandma whose
husband just died is she a modern woman
no you know you know that's what I'm
saying so like when we use these words
it's like what are people saying so
let's just this is a general word let's
say women between the ages of 20 18
through 40. usually young young women
who are dating are they like that first
and foremost generalizations do well on
the internet women today are delusional
men today are irresponsible
generalizations do well for click bait
but they don't do well in the
conversation because you cannot
generalize all people into one group so
when you're saying all modern women are
you telling me that the women in Seattle
Washington are the same as women in
Birmingham Alabama are you telling the
women in New York in Manhattan New York
City are the same woman as Des Moines
Iowa it's not the same thing and anyone
who's been around the country can tell
you this there's Nuance there's there is
universal similarities because we're all
in the same country but there is Nuance
right like the the the the liberal
leaning person in freaking Portland
Oregon is totally different than the
liberal leading person in Atlanta
Georgia it's Nuance to the conversation
so the very first thing is that Modern
Woman is a lot of different types of
modern women is there a group of modern
women who don't like men who are not
sexually promiscuous yes there is a
group of modern women who don't like
that but let's define what is going on
when are they simply attracted to the
man because they're simply sexually
promiscuous is that the only thing
that's turning them on but let's no
let's dive into it because like I said
it's a loaded statement what about that
man
that is turning her on because obviously
in in you know in a true kind of a
paradoxical nature she probably doesn't
like the idea of him sleeping around so
why would she be attracted to the idea
of him sleeping around so let's break
down what what is going on so what you
analyze is that usually a guy who is
sleeping around with other women is
usually a guy that other women want
other women desire other women value
other women respect so therefore this is
probably more an established successful
attractive guy that is existing so when
they're looking at the guy and say well
she only they women like him because
he's sleeping around don't that's a
simple narrative me and Francis always
say whenever someone gives you a simple
narrative a complex problem you know
that person has a very myopic solution
and so the biggest issue that you're
realizing is that that's a simple
narrative there's many different factors
to why he's attractive and those
contributing factors will make other
women want to be with him but to Simply
attribute it to the only thing that
these women are turned on by is him
sleeping around and in the other part
women don't want
um
to a man to who respect them right so
it's like is that all women this every
single woman in America not like men who
respect him right do you not like men
who respect you I wouldn't consider
myself a modern woman yes by based on my
definition so my definition the reason I
feel and I I agree that I generally I
generally don't like generalizations I'm
not I'm somebody who for a very long
time in politics refused to say the
right the left because I felt there was
too much Nuance because the left was you
know Joe manchin and who's pretty
moderate and then the left was AOC who's
like all the way out however because of
what's happened with technology now and
because now I feel like women who grow
up in New York City and women who grow
up in a small town in Iowa are exposed
to a lot of the same stuff via social
media I feel really comfortable saying
that a vast majority of modern young
women are absorbing and regurgitating
feminist garbage modern feminist garbage
there's too many of them and when I came
into this debate it's interesting
because I was a little bit defensive
because I was hearing people in the red
pill Community mostly men talk about
women like women are doing this and
women are doing that I'm a woman right
so I'm like hold up you know I didn't
live like that I don't do that I wasn't
walking into the the sexual Marketplace
and advertising this and that and you
know I wasn't sleeping around so I was
Defensive because I wanted to protect
the idea that there are women like me
and that those women do still exist
however
as I've just absorbed so much content
and watched so many women talk I'm
horrified by how many young women are
comfortable being [ __ ] or comfortable
being promiscuous or comfortable acting
like what I used to call badly behave
men but when I what I say when I say
that I mean men who are promiscuous men
who sleep around they've lost what makes
women to me valuable and special and
beautiful now that makes a lot of sense
and to me I I agree and but like I said
I want to take a bit deeper so we do
live in a digital age so culture now
gets permeated a lot faster and is able
to be spread a lot quicker right so
because of the digital age things that
are culturally relevant in a New York
City can also be culturally relevant in
a place like St Paul's Minnesota right
so is it there is that cultural thing
that goes on so there are similarities
right I will never deny there are
similarities that are going on in
today's society between all different
groups my biggest argument is that to
the to the levels that it exists in
certain places like you go to Miami
Florida Miami has a huge sugar baby
Instagram culture Atlanta is the very
same you can't you cannot tell me oh the
same sugar baby culture in Miami is also
going on in South Dakota at the same
levels and percentages it's not not like
there's Nuance to it and so while I do
agree with you that there is cultural
things going on with women where they
are more sexually promiscuous there is
this only fans culture I'm agreeing that
there is a culture but what I don't like
and this is what why I'm always trying
to bring Nuance to the conversation is
that so many men think that everybody
they think it's every single woman is
like this right it's like political
every person who's right leaning is a
mega person a die-hard mega every
person's like I don't like because then
there's no longer a conversation with
the people and instead with I truly
believe is in today's society we have to
celebrate what we want to see more of
that's how you incentivize good behavior
if all we do is spend all our time
talking about the craziest most
delusional unhealthy toxic women they're
getting attention that's their currency
in today's age the currency of today's
error is attention so if you're spending
all of our time energy effort and
talking about them giving them abuse
giving them attention versus
incentivizing women such as yourself
classy women instead of talking about
them giving them likes giving them
content we need to incentivize them
because when a young woman goes on the
internet and she's seen all those other
girls are going viral she's gonna be
more incentivized to do that behavior
versus let's incentivize the others so I
agree with you that there is a cultural
issue amongst women we can talk about
how it's gotten there but my biggest
thing is that by by simply making it
seem like it's all women it discourages
men it also encourages young women to
continue that behavior if you want to
watch the full episode click right here
and if you want to ask me a question and
talk one-on-one send me a FaceTime video
join a video with a group of your
friends and me you gotta download manect
and you gotta join me there it's gonna
be really hot
[Music]